yy EU package
Forcing Poland to relocate
to receive illegal
Immigrants Presented as Refugees
should be rejected
this is not a solution
which serves to defend borders
this is the solution
which is to institutionalize
a huge stream of millions
People from Asia and Africa
who would like to get into this
The wealth reserve of the European Union
there is no basis
What the German government is funding
Ships that carry people
From the coast of Africa
The North can be considered a crisis.
This is not a crisis
This is the result of European countries
you have to stop using force
As Australia does
The Australian Coast Guard has the right to use force.
to turn the boat around
This strategy works
Simultaneously
The strategy of the Morawiecki government must be rejected
Open Borders Strategy
where we are record holders in the European Union
When it comes to legal
Mass uncontrolled labour migration
The Confederation proposes a package
A responsible migration policy
Let us be wise before harm
Do not repeat the mistakes of the West
Poland needs an honest debate on this issue.
where the money will come from
for which we will maintain pensions
We have one of the lowest retirement ages yy in Europe
We have a demographic crisis
Tackling labour market shortages
Mass immigration will cause problems.
everyone is aware of it
No one has the courage to say
A regulation must be issued
limiting the influx of foreigners to Poland
When it comes to retirement age
I want to allay the fears spread by the media
confederation
He is not in favor of raising the retirement age.
if Poles ever want it
may voluntarily stay longer in the labour market
and solutions to motivate this
They should be conducted
The real problem is this
that as Poles we are currently financing pensions
for another nation
for the Ukrainian people
on the basis of the agreement concluded by the government of Donald Tusk
and unspoken by the government
This is a real scandal
because it is enough to work in Poland for 1 day
reach retirement age
declare
that you live here and the Polish taxpayer has to pay
several times higher minimum pension
This must be said immediately
Current level of social benefits
very expanded
for which they voted together
all other parties here
It is financed by debt
There is no more money in Poland.
In the coming year,
Poland will have to
in international markets
borrowing 420
Billions of dollars just for that
to service the debt and finance it all
We offer savings in the first place
Social Security for Ukrainians
It cannot be a Polish taxpayer.
Funding 500 + 800 plus
family care capital 300 plus em
2% loans for this
for Ukrainians to paint real estate here
It s too much we can t afford it
it needs to be trimmed and this is a savings proposition
when it comes to benefits for Poles
If there is money
They must be maintained
Above all,
taxation should be reduced.
Poverty comes from inflation
with new costs
which also Prime Minister Morawiecki
With the support of the left and platform
took to Poland in the form of fit for fifty five in the form of
Different types of obligations in capo
which are not honestly reported to the public
which caused only for the last term of the government the inscription
Increase in electricity prices by 60%
Forests are strategic assets for the entire economy.
They should not be sold
They should not be privatized.
should also take care of
so that unprocessed wood does not leave Poland
because it hits the Polish gate
that the tree hits the Polish
furniture industry an important export industry
At the moment unfortunately
This wood is missing.
attention should also be paid to other companies of importance
Strategic
pisa built around orlen a real behemoth
it's not safe
integrating so many companies yy under 1 hand
sold to foreign capital
large parts of the lotus
Most important are investments
which are just coming
Central communication port
nuclear power plants
We do not have a specific ownership structure.
After 8 years of government,
he was unable to
Is it the property of the Polish state?
or international capital
There must be clear decisions
state control and above all we need to know
At what price will electricity be sold to Poles?
because writing makes propaganda of success
And so the basic facts as who has to pay for it
and how much he did not determine
Poland must be strong
Poland must be armed.
but who has to handle it all
at the moment we are dealing with
with a kind of success propaganda
It means the government with 8 years of its power
6 7 slept
at the moment
when the crisis on the border with Belarus began
woke up and went into a shopping spree
Unfortunately not in the Polish defense industry.
Mostly abroad
Sometimes products of inferior quality
than we are able to produce here
But you have to build production lines first.
to produce here
when production lines are in Korea or America
This is where we buy at the moment,
indebted to the power
on an exorbitant scale
Regardless of this
that it raises huge debts
We need a strong army
We need soldiers
who will handle it all
with high qualifications
we must attract them with good salaries
respect for the Polish uniform is needed
which Minister Błaszczak does not show
instrumental and propagandistic use of the military
Border must be protected
We cannot give in to any political correctness.
every piece of Polish territory must be defended
The view presented by the government
High inflation goes hand in hand with a good life.
The economy is simply wrong.
We have high inflation and we have just entered a recession.
yy 42%
More companies want to register this year
than in the previous
is not a coincidence
The government itself destroyed the Polish
in Poland gave jobs
Giant funding from an international corporation
Like Volkswagen or Intel
30% of total investment
and a Polish entrepreneur
or persons conducting business activity
increased zus
very consistently
or even banned economic activity
made Sunday's super economic dictator
which stated
It closes tourism.
Closes the culture
Closes the gastronomy
It closes almost everything
Where there was no capital
foreign
to this come yet
yy restrictions in agriculture
Attempt to outlaw part of meat exports
attempt to outlaw part of breeding
Well, there is nothing to be surprised
that it finally ends in the Chełm half